Jake:耶你气的
Jake: Yeah, you're angry.
Jake:你眼你眼镜呢我靠
Jake: Your glasses, where are your glasses? Damn.
Jake:卖卖瓜丢了个眼镜
Jake: Selling melons and lost glasses.
Lucia: 我靠
Lucia: Damn.
Jake:1234
Jake: 1, 2, 3, 4.
Jake:5
Jake: 5.
Jake:哎呀哎呀
Jake: Oh dear, oh dear.
Jake:插线板拔了吧
Jake: Unplug the power strip.
Jake:咱把插线板都都给拔了吧
Jake: Let's unplug all the power strips.
Shure: 好嘞好嘞
Shure: Got it, got it.
Shure: 辛苦你
Shure: Thanks for the hard work.
Shure: 然后打车票子啥的你就留好
Shure: Keep your taxi receipts and stuff.
Jake:啊嗨嗨
Jake: Ah, sure, sure.
Shure: 到时候跟那个小畅报
Shure: Report them to Xiaochang later.
Shure: 啾啾啾
Shure: Choo choo choo.
Tasha: 这是什么
Tasha: What is this?
Shure: 那个打孔器
Shure: That's a puncher.
Shure: 打耳洞的
Shure: For ear piercing.
Tasha: 真的假的
Tasha: Really?
Shure: 真的呀
Shure: Yes.
Shure: 你看那不还有碘伏呢吗
Shure: See, there's iodine there.
Shure: 然后涂完碘伏然后把耳耳朵夹在里面
Shure: After applying iodine, clamp your ear in it.
Shure: 然后一摁
Shure: Then press it.
Alice:啊
Alice: Ah.
Tasha: 真的假的
Tasha: Really?
Shure: 对啊就穿过去了
Shure: Yeah, it goes through.
Shure: 没想到吧
Shure: Surprised, right?
Jake:哼哼确实没想到哼
Jake: Hmm, indeed surprising. Hmm.
Jake:确实很难想这个
Jake: It's really hard to think about this.
Shure: 试试
Shure: Try it.
Lucia: 想不起来了
Lucia: I can't remember.
Shure: 是不是差点就信了
Shure: You almost believed it, didn't you?
Shure: 哈哈哈哈哈
Shure: Hahahahaha.
Shure: 对不起
Shure: Sorry.
Shure: 怎么样怎么样这个
Shure: How about this one?
Jake:哈喽
Jake: Hello.
Alice:刚看到消息
Alice: Just saw the message.
Shure: 有
Shure: There is.
Shure: 很有用
Shure: Very useful.
Alice:搁哪
Alice: Where is it?
Shure: 这几个是谢彬竹的那个我靠
Shure: These are Xie Binzhu's, oh my gosh.
Shure: 还有一个应该
Shure: There should be one more.
Alice:那要不你给他收起来
Alice: How about you put it away for him?
Shure: 啊对
Shure: Ah, right.
Shure: 这四个是谢彬竹的
Shure: These four are Xie Binzhu's.
Shure: 这个是杨老板
Shure: This one is Jake's.
Jake:啊
Jake: Ah.
Shure: 杨老板这个是什么的
Shure: Jake, what is this for?
Jake:哎
Jake: Hmm.
Jake:哦
Jake: Oh.
Jake:12345有5个
Jake: There are five, 12345.
Jake:这边不用翻
Jake: No need to flip here.
Jake:但是没地放
Jake: But there's no place to put them.
Jake:放后面随便找地放
Jake: Just find a spot in the back to put them.
Jake:这一层就5个
Jake: There are five on this level.
Jake:这种目一词
Jake: This kind of wood.
Alice:这是不是搬下去啊
Alice: Should we move this down?
Alice:这个木凳子
Alice: This wooden bench.
Shure: 我总不能背着他背回去吧
Shure: I can't possibly carry it back by myself, right?
其他人：嗯你要是
Others: Hmm, if you...
Shure: 我 不会的不是
Shure: I can't, no way.
Jake:呵呵呵儿子
Jake: Haha, son.
其他人：我说你要是从学校去的话
Others: I'm saying if you're coming from school...
其他人：我们呢倒是有
Others: We do have...
Alice:这也是垃圾吧
Alice: This is trash, right?
Jake:嗯
Jake: Yeah.
Shure: 我上个厕所
Shure: I'm going to the bathroom.
其他人：你是不是还有一个外套在我那
Others: Don't you have another jacket with me?
Shure: 好像是
Shure: Seems like it
Jake:眼镜呢
Jake: Where are the glasses?
Jake:哎眼镜呢
Jake: Hey, where are the glasses?
Shure: 眼镜在这
Shure: The glasses are here
Jake:哦那请
Jake: Oh, then please
Jake:请上请上
Jake: Please go ahead
Jake:没关系哈哈哈
Jake: It's okay, hahaha
Shure: 这需要这样的数据题吗
Shure: Do we need such data questions?
Jake:导演也没那么需要
Jake: The director doesn't really need them that much
Jake:但是我们也不太排斥
Jake: But we don't really reject them either
Jake:哈哈虽然不需要
Jake: Haha, even though we don't need them
Shure: 哈哈哈
Shure: Hahaha
Shure: yes案s是吧
Shure: Yes or no, right?
Jake:不需要但是也行啊
Jake: Don't need them but it's fine too
其他人：真不是同款
Others: It's really not the same style
其他人：我那天看了
Others: I saw it that day
其他人：那天穿我看真不是同款
Others: I saw it that day, it's really not the same style
Jake:这个地为什么会这样呢
Jake: Why is this place like this?
Lucia: 可能有饮料之类东西
Lucia: Maybe there were some drinks or something
Lucia: 然后他有糖就
Lucia: And then it had sugar so
Jake:嗯一地的糖
Jake: Hmm, sugar all over the place
Jake:好嘞
Jake: Got it
Lucia: 现在
Lucia: Now
Lucia: 它的整齐程度就和昨天一模一样
Lucia: The tidiness level is the same as yesterday
Jake:嗯好
Jake: Hmm, good
Lucia: 我我现在是不是要到外面还是
Lucia: Should I go outside now or
Jake:呃还没
Jake: Uh, not yet
Jake:还有几个人
Jake: There are still a few people
Jake:呵呵对
Jake: Haha, right
Lucia: 啊那行
Lucia: Ah, okay then
Jake:等人齐了一起走
Jake: We'll go together when everyone's here
Lucia: 好
Lucia: Okay
Lucia: 东西整理整理
Lucia: Organize things a bit
Lucia: 哦这我昨天那个那个啥
Lucia: Oh, this is the thing from yesterday, that thing
Katrina: 放那了
Katrina: Put it there
Lucia: 放这吧他还可以出镜一下
Lucia: Put it here, it can still show up on camera
Jake:好
Jake: Okay
Katrina: 可以扫吗
Katrina: Can I sweep?
Katrina: 可以先扫我的吗
Katrina: Can I sweep mine first?
Katrina: 因为我有点想睡觉
Katrina: Because I'm feeling a bit sleepy.
Jake:想睡觉
Jake: Feeling sleepy?
Katrina: 我有点不舒服
Katrina: I'm feeling a bit unwell.
Jake:好的行呃
Jake: Okay, sure.
Lucia: 这个是不可以扔掉
Lucia: This can't be thrown away.
Lucia: 这好像也是我昨天的墙贴
Lucia: I think this is the wall sticker I put up yesterday.
Lucia: 这是效果示意图
Lucia: This is the effect diagram.
Jake:好哈哈可以
Jake: Okay, haha, that's fine.
Jake:微微准备下去吧
Jake: Tasha, get ready to go down.
Jake:在吗
Jake: Are you there?
Jake:准备下去吧
Jake: Get ready to go down.
Jake:嗯
Jake: Hmm.
Jake:走走走
Jake: Let's go, let's go.
Jake:走啦走啦走啦走啦走啦
Jake: Let's go, let's go, let's go, let's go.
Lucia: 我不下去行不行
Lucia: Can I not go down?
Jake:哎这是一个好主意
Jake: Hey, that's a good idea.
Jake:那你不能动
Jake: But you can't move.
Jake:你得是可以
Jake: You have to be still.
Jake:可以可以
Jake: Okay, okay.
Jake:可以可以可以可以可以可以可以
Jake: Okay, okay, okay, okay, okay, okay, okay.
Lucia: 我自己也想拍一下
Lucia: I want to take a picture myself.
Jake:好可以拍一下
Jake: Sure, you can take a picture.
Jake:真好看小写生活大写爱
Jake: It's really beautiful. Small letters for life, big letters for love.
Lucia: 谢谢
Lucia: Thank you.
Jake:生活不在别处
Jake: Life is not elsewhere.
Jake:嗯
Jake: Hmm.
Jake:还有一种方案
Jake: There's another plan.
Jake:就是你们就在自己的房间
Jake: Which is you stay in your room.
Jake:但是不能动
Jake: But you can't move.
Lucia: 我下去吧
Lucia: I'll go down.
Jake:哈哈哈哈哈
Jake: Hahaha.
Lucia: 哈哈难度好高哈哈哈
Lucia: Haha, that's really challenging, haha.
Jake:就是
Jake: Exactly.
Jake:你们就成为你们房间里边的一个
Jake: You guys will become part of your room's decor.
Lucia: 装饰是吧
Lucia: Like decoration, right?
Jake:对对对好可怕啊
Jake: Yes, yes, it's so scary.
Lucia: 好可怕啊
Lucia: So scary.
Lucia: 现在的研究已经进行到这一步了吗
Lucia: Has the research already reached this stage?
Jake:这个就是一个示意图形就是
Jake: This is just a conceptual diagram.
Jake:那你到时候就这么坐着
Jake: Then you'll just sit like this at that time.
Tasha: 我扒动我扒动
Tasha: I'm moving it, I'm moving it
Jake:你扒东好你扒东
Jake: You're moving it well, you're moving it well
Lucia: 哇我真的对这个非常满意
Lucia: Wow, I'm really satisfied with this
Lucia: 再给我多点时间
Lucia: Give me a bit more time
Lucia: 我甚至还能把那个鱼和海浪
Lucia: I can even make the fish and the waves
Lucia: 给他装饰的更像一点
Lucia: look even more realistic
Lucia: 别说您了
Lucia: Don't mention it
Lucia: 我自己都想扫一下
Lucia: I want to scan it myself
Lucia: 哈哈哈哈哈
Lucia: Hahahaha
Jake:你回头也可以自己扫一下
Jake: You can scan it yourself later
Lucia: 就是我应该扫一下
Lucia: I should scan it myself
Lucia: 你用的是哪个软件
Lucia: Which software are you using?
Jake:就是3D scan
Jake: It's 3D scan
Jake:呃对对对
Jake: Uh, yeah, yeah
Lucia: threed scanner那个
Lucia: The 3D scanner one?
Jake:3D SCAN
Jake: 3D SCAN
Lucia: OK我之前用过那个
Lucia: OK, I used that before
Jake:嗯可以
Jake: Hmm, it's good
Tasha: 我也用过
Tasha: I used it too
Tasha: 我帮你扫另一个房间吧
Tasha: I'll help you scan the other room
Lucia: 他要扫一个
Lucia: He needs to scan one
Lucia: 他对他要扫一个连续的文件
Lucia: Yeah, he needs to scan one continuous file
Jake:对
Jake: Yes
Lucia: 我是ready scatter
Lucia: I am ready to scatter
Lucia: 应该还有
Lucia: Should have some left
Lucia: 我上次那个啥的也有可能没有了
Lucia: My last one might not be there anymore
Lucia: 因为我这个软件好久没用了
Lucia: Because I haven't used this software for a while
Alice:我要上个厕所
Alice: I need to go to the bathroom
Jake:嗯
Jake: Hmm
Alice:这不可以录
Alice: This can't be recorded
Jake:好好没问题没问题
Jake: Alright, no problem, no problem
Jake:可以不录
Jake: We won't record
Jake:你也可以在房间里面坐着
Jake: You can sit in the room
Jake:但是不能动
Jake: But don't move
Jake:你作为房间里面的一个
Jake: You'll be part of the room
Katrina: 为什么啊啊
Katrina: Why, ah ah
Jake:哈哈哈哈
Jake: Hahaha
Katrina: 没事你先扫吧我再
Katrina: It's fine, you go ahead and scan first
其他人：您咋还给那狗拿过来了
Others: Why did you bring the dog here?
Jake:哎呀不好意思你在那边哎
Jake: Oh, sorry, you're over there, oh
其他人：没事没事
Others: It's okay, it's okay.
Jake:对对对狗狗我放门口
Jake: Yeah, yeah, I'll put the dog at the door.
其他人：撩这吧那就
Others: Let's go then.
Jake:对
Jake: Yes.
Jake:内有恶犬
Jake: Beware of the dog inside.
Jake:哈哈哈
Jake: Hahaha.
Lucia: 哈哈可以
Lucia: Haha, sure.
Jake:哎正好给你一个升级垃圾桶
Jake: Hey, just in time, let me give you an upgraded trash can.
Shure: 太不好了整个人
Shure: This is so bad, really.
Shure: 今天要把这个房子拆成什么样
Shure: How are we going to tear down this house today?
Shure: 就是完全恢复原样
Shure: Like, completely restore it?
Jake:啥啥啥啥啥
Jake: What, what, what?
Shure: 我说我们今天要把这房子拆成什么样
Shure: I said, how are we going to tear down this house today?
Jake:拆成原样
Jake: Restore it to its original state.
Jake:你你拿的时候记得啥样不
Jake: Do you remember how it looked when you took it?
Shure: 那个什么go Pro的时候也拆
Shure: Even the GoPro has to be dismantled.
Jake:那当然得拆
Jake: Of course, it has to be dismantled.
Shure: 今天都拆了是吗
Shure: Everything gets dismantled today, right?
Jake:今晚都拆
Jake: Everything gets dismantled tonight.
Shure: OK
Shure: OK.
Jake:对我这电脑也要全拆了
Jake: Yeah, my computer also needs to be completely dismantled.
Lucia: well
Lucia: Well.
Jake:哦呦
Jake: Oh man.
Lucia: sorry
Lucia: Sorry.
Jake:我这电脑还得全
Jake: My computer has to be...
Jake:也得全拆了
Jake: Completely dismantled too.
Jake:回头你们还能打把麻将
Jake: Later, you guys can still play mahjong.
Shure: 哎呦哎呦
Shure: Oh man, oh man.
Jake:开心了不
Jake: Are you happy now?
Shure: 快快拆
Shure: Quick, dismantle it.
Jake:哈哈哈哈哈哈哈
Jake: Hahahahahaha.
Shure: 我觉得杨老板这屋拆的刻不容缓
Shure: I think Jake's room needs to be dismantled immediately.
Shure: 因为他一直压着那麻将机
Shure: Because he's been blocking the mahjong table.
Lucia: 这就是你一直没能打上的原因是
Lucia: So that's why you haven't been able to play?
Shure: 对啊
Shure: Yeah.
Jake:对等了一周了
Jake: Yeah, I've been waiting for a week.
Jake:可算能打上了
Jake: Finally can play now.
Jake:呵垂涎三尺
Jake: Been drooling for it.
Lucia: 哎呀这就剩一个了
Lucia: Oh, there's just one left.
Lucia: 我给大家收拾收拾尾声
Lucia: Let me clean up the end for everyone.
Jake:对是是一个麻将的尾声
Jake: Yeah, it's the end of a mahjong game.
Jake:然后谁谁赢先谁先走
Jake: Then whoever wins first gets to leave first.
Jake:呵呵谁赢谁先走
Jake: Haha, whoever wins gets to leave first.
Lucia: 是是吗
Lucia: Is that right?
Jake:谁先胡谁先胡谁先走
Jake: Whoever wins first, leaves first.
Jake:不胡不准走
Jake: If you don't win, you can't leave.
Shure: 哈哈哈
Shure: Hahaha
Lucia: 不准走妈呀
Lucia: You can't leave, oh my god.
Katrina: 哈哈哈妈呀
Katrina: Hahaha, oh my god.
Jake:哈哈哈哈哈
Jake: Hahahahaha
Shure: 锁好门我要胡把大的
Shure: Lock the door, I want to win big.
Lucia: 那我这种不会打的球走不了了
Lucia: Then I, who can't play, won't be able to leave.
Jake:哈哈
Jake: Haha
Jake:没一个
Jake: Not a single one.
Jake:哈哈
Jake: Haha
Lucia: 就没有人管我了是吗
Lucia: So no one is going to care about me, huh?
Lucia: 那是我裤子吗
Lucia: Are those my pants?
Lucia: 这么长时间还没洗完吗
Lucia: They've been washing for so long?
Jake:那女的半个小时挺长
Jake: Half an hour is pretty long for a woman.
Lucia: 哦既然不是
Lucia: Oh, since it's not...
Lucia: 是哪位好心人已经帮我把裤子挂上了
Lucia: Which kind person already hung up my pants?
Jake:哦
Jake: Oh.
Lucia: 我就说他应该好了
Lucia: I knew it should be done by now.
Lucia: 没洗这么久
Lucia: It hasn't been washing that long.
Shure: 粉的
Shure: Pink.
Shure: 要试试吗
Shure: Want to try it?
其他人：妈呀
Others: Oh my god.
Shure: 粉的哈哈哈
Shure: Pink, hahaha.
Jake:嚯这是要跳舞这是
Jake: Whoa, is someone going to dance?
Jake:上广场这是
Jake: Heading to the square?
Shure: 我妈买的
Shure: My mom bought it.
Shure: 哈哈哈少什么奶奶
Shure: Hahaha, what about grandma?
Shure: 哈哈哈那叫老夫人
Shure: Hahaha, we call her the old lady.
Shure: 我在这修了一下午的那那什么家呀
Shure: I spent the whole afternoon fixing that, you know, the house.
Shure: 墙啊桥结果我妹没给
Shure: The wall, the bridge, but my sister didn't...
Shure: 我保存直接给我退了
Shure: save it and just quit.
Jake:好啊动森
Jake: Oh, Animal Crossing.
Jake:疫情那会躺床上就晚是吧
Jake: During the pandemic, just lying in bed, right?
Jake:疫情刚开始那会是
Jake: When the pandemic first started.
其他人：那师傅几条腿
Others: How many legs does the master have?
其他人：谢斌竹给你带这么多裤子
Others: Xie Binzhu brought you so many pants.
Shure: 谁知道啊
Shure: Who knows.
Shure: 有些为什么
Shure: Some for some reason.
Shure: 跟我熟人
Shure: They're from people I know.
Shure: 他就给我带了一件白t四件外套
Shure: He just brought me one white T-shirt and four jackets.
Shure: 哈哈哈真是正常人类能带过来了
Shure: Hahaha, like a normal person could bring all that.
Jake:哈哈哈哈
Jake: Hahahaha
Lucia: 我可以认领一下这个箱子
Lucia: Can I claim this suitcase?
Jake:我要开始扫了可以了吗
Jake: Can I start sweeping now? Is that okay?
Alice:那我下去那我下去
Alice: Then I'll go downstairs, I'll go downstairs.
Alice:把袜子粘粘
Alice: Stick the socks together.
Jake:那你就坐着
Jake: Then you just sit.
Jake:你不能动
Jake: You can't move.
Jake:你摆个好pose
Jake: Strike a good pose.
Jake:哈哈哈你总之是不能动
Jake: Hahaha, basically, you can't move.
Jake:别都行
Jake: Do whatever else.
Jake:别的干啥都行
Jake: Do anything else you want.
Jake:你真不能动啊
Jake: You really can't move, huh?
Jake:好
Jake: Alright.
Jake:是有人来了吗
Jake: Is someone here?
Lucia: 有一个快递来了
Lucia: A delivery arrived.
Jake:哦
Jake: Oh.
Jake:你的店
Jake: Your store.
Jake:别忘了星之卡比
Jake: Don't forget Kirby.
Jake:一会在我来之前要弄完
Jake: Finish it before I come back.
Jake:一会我要扫这边所以
Jake: I need to sweep this side later.
Tasha: 我
Tasha: I...
Jake:OK OK
Jake: OK, OK.
Jake:我上面可能扫他个20分钟吧
Jake: I'll sweep upstairs for maybe 20 minutes.
Jake:然后20分钟之后
Jake: And then after 20 minutes,
Jake:你们就要悄悄的跑到二楼去躲着对
Jake: You all need to quietly run to the second floor and hide, right?
Alice:我是监工
Alice: I'm the supervisor.
Jake:上装备开凿
Jake: Gear up and start drilling.
Jake:插管
Jake: Insert the pipe.
Jake:哈哈插一圈管开扫
Jake: Haha, insert the pipe all around and start sweeping.
Jake:哎
Jake: Hey.
Jake:你都行
Jake: You can do it.
Jake:你可以不动
Jake: You can stay still.
Jake:哎人呢
Jake: Hey, where is everyone?
Jake:哎我靠
Jake: Hey, damn.
Jake:你可以不动
Jake: You can stay still.
Jake:也可以躲着我
Jake: Or you can hide from me.
Jake:那你就不动吧
Jake: Then just stay still.
Jake:好吧
Jake: Alright.
Jake:哎嘿嘿
Jake: Haha.
Jake:不算不算不算
Jake: Doesn't count, doesn't count, doesn't count.
Jake:行我先扫礼吧好吧
Jake: Okay, I'll sweep the area first, alright?
Jake:没有没有
Jake: No, no.
Jake:还没开始
Jake: Haven't started yet.
Jake:按了按了按了
Jake: Pressed it, pressed it, pressed it.
Tasha: 开始了
Tasha: Started.
Jake:开始了开始了
Jake: Started, started.
Jake:别动不准动
Jake: Don't move, no moving.
Tasha: 结束了吗
Tasha: Is it over?
Jake:结束你可以动
Jake: It's over, you can move.
Jake:你动也不能出来哦
Jake: Even if you move, you can't come out.
Jake:你只能在床上动
Jake: You can only move on the bed.
Jake:你不能露出头
Jake: You can't show your head.
Jake:你就会选一个你的头
Jake: You'll just pick one spot for your head.
Jake:在某一个地方
Jake: In one place.
Tasha: 好我同意了
Tasha: Okay, I agree.
Jake:你统一选一个头是吧
Jake: So you agree to pick one spot for your head, right?
Jake:同意的是什么
Jake: What did you agree to?
Jake:别动别动别动别动别动
Jake: Don't move, don't move, don't move, don't move.
Jake:没有没有没啥事
Jake: No, no, nothing's wrong.
Jake:但是就是别动
Jake: Just don't move.
Tasha: hello
Tasha: Hello.
Jake:hello
Jake: Hello.
Tasha: OK你不在OK come on
Tasha: Okay, you're not here, okay, come on.
Jake:哈喽我在
Jake: Hello, I'm here.